vamos a aprender un poquito acerca del
maravilloso mundo de los logaritmos así
que hasta ahora ya sabemos cómo tomar
exponentes si fuera yo a decir 2 a la 4
2 a la cuarta potencia que sería bueno
esto es 2 por dos por dos por dos
ok 2 2 que se multiplica por si mismo
cuatro veces ok y así esto va a ser 2
por 2 4 por 2 8 por 2 16 esto es 16 pero
qué tal si pensamos de otra forma qué
tal si yo tuviera que 16 es igual a 2
elevado alguna potencia o que es por
ejemplo digamos que empiezo con 2 a la
alguna potencia que voy a llamar x esto
me va a dar 16 ok
bueno simplemente sabemos que esto debe
ser 4 verdad por lo anterior
y esto es lo que hacen los logaritmos
fundamentalmente descubren cuál es la
potencia a la cual tienes que elevar
otro número para que te dé cierto número
así que ahora la forma en la que
denotamos el logaritmo es de la
siguiente forma decimos blog blog más
déjenme déjenme de hacerlo más colorido
log base 2 en este caso déjenme pintarlo
de azul logaritmo log base 2 de 16 vamos
a pintar esto de filia de 16 es igual y
en este caso va a ser x verdad x
es igual a equis y esto es completamente
equivalente a esta otra cosa como lo
define esto estamos diciendo bueno vamos
a tomar dos alguna potencia x para
obtener 16 esto están preguntando a qué
potencia debe elevarse el 2 para que nos
dé 16 ya ese número le llamamos equis y
vamos a decir que tenemos que elevarlo a
la cuarta potencia ok con esto ya ha
puesto en el camino vamos a hacer
algunos ejemplos evaluando expresiones
logarítmicas así que digamos que tenemos
log
el logaritmo base 3 de 81 a que será
igual esto ok
pues bueno solo como un recuerdo un
recordatorio esto nos dice a qué
potencia tenemos que elevar 3 para que
nos dé 81 así que si queremos podemos
poner esto igual a equis y esencialmente
lo que tenemos que hacer es es
replantear esto de la siguiente forma 3
a la equis a la potencia de x es igual a
81 x porque es tan útil el logaritmo
bueno ya veremos que tiene propiedades
interesantes más adelante pero
necesariamente no tenemos que hacer
ninguna álgebra simplemente podríamos
estar experimentando un poquito con los
exponentes y ver cómo se comportan estos
logaritmos ok sólo podríamos decir esto
es lo mismo
a la potencia que necesitó elevar 3 para
que nos dé 81 ok pero bueno cuál es esa
potencia a la cual tengo que elevar 3
vamos a experimentar un poco 3 por 3 9
por 3 son 3 9 por 3 son 27 por 3 es
igual a 8127 por 3 81 así que esto fue 3
a la 4
nos dio 81 finalmente nuestro valor x es
decir el logaritmo base 3 base 3 de 81
va a ser igual a 4 déjenme hacerlo con
otro color
esto es igual a 4
vamos a hacer otros varios ejemplos más
para para que realmente quede bien
afianzada de esta idea de lo que son los
logaritmos vamos a intentar un número
más grande digamos que queremos
evaluar el logaritmo base 6 de 216 que
va a ser esto
bueno nos estamos preguntando a qué
potencia tengo que elevar 6 para que nos
dé 216 así que la primera potencia de 6
por 6 36 por 6 son 36 por 6 ahí son 216
muy bien así que 6 al cubo es igual a
216 si alguien nos dice a qué potencia
tengo que elevar 6 para obtener 10 216
bueno simplemente eso va a ser un 36 al
cubo o 6 a la tercera potencia es igual
a 216 vamos a intentar otro digamos que
tengo que tengo no sé logaritmo base 2
de 64
esto a que será igual
bueno otra vez nos estamos preguntando
en realidad es el exponente al cual
tengo que elevar el 2 que es nuestra
base para obtener un 64
así que 2 por 2 son 4 por 2 8 por 2 16
por 2 son 32 por 2 son 64 así que
tuvimos 2 a la sexta potencia es igual a
64 así que cuando evaluamos esta
expresión en realidad de cuál es la
potencia a la cual tengo que elevar el 2
para que dé 64 es 16 es la sexta
potencia vamos a hacer uno un poquito
más más directo o quizás sea menos
directo dependiendo de cómo lo veas cuál
es el logaritmo base
de 1
pensemos en eso por un segundo
ok el logaritmo base 100 de 1 quizás
debo ponerlo ahí entre paréntesis para
que quede claro qué será
bueno nos estamos preguntando nuevamente
vamos a evaluar esto como que potencia
debo elevar 100 para que me dé 1 ok a
qué potencia debo elevar 100 para que me
dé 1 déjenme escribirlo esto como una
ecuación si esto es x es literalmente
nos dicen 100 a la x es igual a 1
bueno cualquier cosa elevado a la cero
potencia es igual a 1 así que x es igual
a 0 el logaritmo base 100 de 1 es igual
a 0
de hecho el logaritmo base lo que tú
quieras de uno va a ser siempre igual a
cero porque cualquier cosa a la 0 es 1
ok entonces bueno la base solo hay que
pedirle que no sea 0 por ahora es todo
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo